[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want
hip-hop for no reason record
[Laughter]
bam how is
you know that song too what are you
sipping on joe
oh snaps you're drinking what is he
sipping on
oh but that's chaser though what was you
drinking on
whiskey i said wait i'm waiting
i'm gonna do real i'm gonna do a real
one for the patreon so you guys didn't
see that yeah no give it to me
he's just sipping it i mean no let me
let me explain something really he's not
getting lit up he's not getting explain
something so look
this is how much he has in his cup right
he i'm not trying to get litty
two drops more than this when he poured
it no i did it i
already drank three more oh four drops
no okay four drops sorry four drops so
the point is this isn't the episode
where he's trying to get lit
for i just don't want you to teach women
how to take advantage of me
so true uh don't tell them that [ __ ]
damn let's change the subject so true
let's change it
so julia have you been good you cut your
thumb
yeah why were you cooking again yeah i
was making curry and i was cutting
potatoes and then my friend was telling
a really lame joke and it was so lame
that i got really distracted and then i
cut my thumb
oh i thought it was so lame that you're
like i hate you i want to kill myself
you gotta tell the joke
because of your stupid joke never done i
don't even remember what the joke was
oh jokes on you have you been making
uh curry every day because i've been
looking at your stories
and i was like damn dude you make curry
every day well okay so i have a friend
that likes to eat
three things and he likes to eat them in
rotation and he like makes everything
yeah three things i don't know why but
that's just how [ __ ]
are you okay those four drops got to him
man
i'll watch that play out so maybe this
is the video that's
that we've all been waiting for because
that's for patreon yeah
this is right patreon is he's gonna do a
shot no
this is still pretty regular joe
actually yeah so why
why did that's ocd
that's like i gotta put on my right shoe
before my left shoe or else i get bad
luck
like three things in order just realize
i always do that
well like no so he doesn't rotation so
for one whole week
he'll have curry and then for another
whole week he'll have like beef
stroganoff and another one like tikka
masala wait and he just a whole week he
eats
the same whole week and i have no idea
how he does it that many times in a row
is a heavy thing bruh
and also tiki masala is pretty heavy
like what he does he only means we eat
one meal a day
wait is it is it like a like a meal prep
style thing where it's like you cook it
all
and then there's so much leftovers that
last of the week so you just eat it
pretty much that
yeah so every day it's curry every day
it's beef stroganoff every day tikka
masala and he comes back to the curry
yeah
and so when he's on his curry week me
and my boyfriend like to jump in on that
be like yo let's make some curry
together
yeah that's cute what kind of curry
japanese curry do we have really bad
health
no he's not fat seems like he has bad
cholesterol or something
maybe he just eats one meal a day maybe
it's just really good portion control
maybe it's maybelline
or maybe it's like the maybe it's
maybelline or maybe it's like not the
vegan version but like the
the healthy version the light the
stroganoff light
like spam light yeah there we go stews
though
stews and thick things like that uh-huh
my [ __ ] how much i love sauces salty not
sweet that's my whole [ __ ]
you don't have a sweet tooth not really
what happened to that why
i think that my family is pretty
diabetic so i just
have a natural aversion to sweets yeah
but my family's hella diabetic and i'm
just like i can't stop
i think i got lucky on it i guess i
don't like
candy anything that's that's lucky to
you yeah i think so
well because i don't try to eat it i
don't [ __ ] with candy but pastries
something about that makes sense but
then there's the other side that doesn't
make sense what's the other side
it doesn't make sense well all the
things that you're the sweet things
you're missing out on i could [ __ ] up
like sour candy though
don't even [ __ ] with me but i it's about
if i have it
it produces too much phlegm for me so
it's not that fun oh
so you got uh consequences for those
actions exactly i really
recently started experiencing that
really like like just like
like right now i'm drinking this and i
can already feel the the the the
build-up
is that the cream or is it because this
[ __ ] is
thick well it's also because you're you
with milk is not a good thing
true my eczema is coming back i cannot
stop drinking alcohol for some reason i
cannot stop drinking milk for something
made a milkshake the other day and then
flared up your eczema like y'all want to
see something gross
yeah this is my hand right now i want to
see what the [ __ ]
there's nothing bro what is that i don't
know what is this
i got i got some dry skin too you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] look at this
nothing oh no i got a little oh
it went away yeah it's nothing like i
got crumblies
i like those like exo comparisons like
oh just kidding
he came over just to rub it in your face
and he doesn't have it anymore i don't
have any
oh man i'm so perfect
exactly no it was there two days ago
i didn't pay attention it went away
that's good stop making fun of me what
do you do is i want to get rid of this
i just stopped you have your depictions
just like you're eating the stuff you're
not supposed to i
okay case this is what's worked for me
and i
time out my cleanses so
um i have trigger parts in my body
right so like this is one of them and
then so like let's say
i'm i'm doing too much like too much
dairy or whatever right this
[ __ ] right here goes
it's time and then if it starts to flare
up
then i know stop that's him with his
hand
yeah so that might be your first and if
you don't stop
it'll go to your other areas and if you
don't stop it'll go to your home next is
your eye
goes from his hands this is my warning
spot and when my morning warning spot
comes it goes
be conscious and maybe even do like a
juice cleanse so skip breakfast
uh do juice cleanse whatever you got to
do and limit
all the uh warning [ __ ] wait for it to
go away for a week
and then you can introduce your bad
habits again bro bad habits i love them
how about you julia cause i know you
you have it you got eczema too yeah i
damn it's an asian thing
i used to have it like all over my hand
right here and then it went away
where right here it used to be your lips
too right i remember i still have them
how do you give hand jobs and blow jobs
uh
i say sorry to my boyfriend wow you said
take this instead
wow the better stuff you know but you
know i also have my other hand too
oh oh
she is a giver i got i got my other hand
and i still
would have been like i got
oh that's rough that might feel good oh
and your elbow would hurt
it's like a dick lock didn't you
actually do that you did the back of the
knee [ __ ] it too
i tried everything yeah with your i'm
gonna armpit
yep yeah neck neck yep behind the ear
what about just going like that whose
penis
[Laughter]
[Music]
what inspired you to make a milkshake
did you see a picture of a milkshake
so i was trying to make something with
matcha
or junebe matcha and i was like oh what
can i make what have i not tried yet
with this
matcha powder and i was like you know
what you made pancakes i've been making
milkshakes for isaac
yeah and i was like what if i just made
it green what if i just put some matcha
in there
that was that was what i did it turned
out great it was delicious
but now i'm suffering
is it that how fast is your trigger like
if you do one milkshake
by the end of the day i can i can feel
it flaring up like it starts burning you
know like eczema feeling it like
starts to burn and you have to also give
a little bit of backstory
because he's also he's on medication
right so this medicine
he you're supposed to take it once a
week but he ends up making it last for
like an entire month yeah don't tell my
insurance company
but yeah i stock up on this [ __ ] i it's
supposed to be every two weeks
oh two weeks yeah but then i spaced it
out so i have a whole bunch of it
in my refrigerator just in case the
world goes to [ __ ] and it seems like
it's going that way
but during the apocalypse that's what
you're worried about yes that's what i
mean i need this you don't know man
it was bad before this drug this drugs
what is this drug
he saved him oh it's called that's true
no i had a really bad episode this year
so yeah so then for that reason i
couldn't get out of bed the fact that
like he'll prolong
the doses that's when it'll come back
and then when he and when he comes back
and then he's doing the milkshake it
just exacerbates it more yeah that's why
exacerbations are taking exacerbates
wait but is it is it hot isn't hot water
bad for
eczema skin no but then like no it's
like the pain
so like i i had that crazy episode this
year where it was like
from neck to [ __ ] toe i had pictures
of that [ __ ]
it was like on my thigh on my knee like
that
unbearable pus itch right
it hurts so much that you wake up in the
middle of the night itching
and then you can't go back to sleep so
you go and take a hot [ __ ] shower to
blast out all the pain and then you go
back to the bed
and you lay down and just like [ __ ] my
life [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you try it to cool it down but it
still doesn't
feel as good as blasting it with hot
water
and then letting it relax after yeah so
then
hot bath that worked out well for me
because i tried everything creams
ice all this [ __ ] but taking a boiling
hot bath
blasting my body away and then the cool
down
was really soothing and that helped me
relax for like two hours when you see
him making a milkshake are you like this
[ __ ]
i actually wasn't home i was filming
here i have to secretly do these things
yes no if i was home i would be like oh
can i have one too
and then i see him drinking it i'll be
like you slap it out of my hands
why don't you use milk alternatives
sometimes milk is just way more better
than oatmeal
as i say oatmeal is pretty bomb though
almond milk is bound
almond milk almond milk what language
are you thinking
almond milk almond milk balm it's bam
bam but i don't like the
oatmeal one i don't like it really i
like it i think
it don't know it's so thick it's a thick
milk yeah
i thought oat milk was pretty good oat
milk is good mixed with coffee you guys
ever tried hemp
milk no never have it's pretty good what
does it taste like
wow they all kind of taste they milk a
[ __ ] marijuana yeah
whoa something like that how do you do
that even the first time i discovered
almond milk i was like how do you milk
an almond
well oh you you soak it and then you
blend it and then you put it through
like a cheesecloth and then you squeeze
strain it yeah you strain it and then
the milk comes out wow
i'm like how do people discover this
farmer was bored
yeah that's exactly how i think they
found most things imagine if you had an
almond farm and you're so [ __ ] tired
of just eating granola bar nuts and it's
like how the [ __ ] can i make this
interesting you know how to make oil
almond oil right and yeah like maybe i
could make some milk
you just start [ __ ] around with it i
mean why do we have crinkle cut fries
cause some guy got bored as [ __ ]
i love crinkle coke fries we were just
talking about it yesterday because we
had del taco
oh yeah we had some del taco and then
what we're talking about crinkle cut not
like the crisscross ones no no no no no
no
they look like a regular fries it looks
like a chip that's right okay so not the
waffle one
time okay got it yeah elementary school
you gotta know your french fries
that's my favorite version of a fry like
my favorite shape of a fry because it's
it has just enough good softness and
then also
crispiness but i don't like crispy too
much because then but i don't like too
much soft either because like the wedges
that's too much sauce
it's a nightmare dude how do you nail it
all down i'm goldilocks
i like to be in the middle coco is also
a great vehicle for ketchup because the
weight yeah
yeah yeah it's very sauce forward i'd
rather have a tater tot than a crinkle
cup
that's too much tater tots too too much
soft for me
i love tater tots anyway because they're
they're small
but like it's a lot it's crunchy yeah
you just gotta find a little better be
crunchy but
it better be you don't like hash brown i
do i love how
i like soggy hash browns it's like soft
[ __ ] drenched in oil it is so good
that's like saying i like a lip dick i
don't know
that's quite the same it's a little bit
of the same no a limb shake is useless
oh like like a soaked hash brown
a soaked hash brown no oh my god don't
be gross right now let's focus on the
topic okay
i like crunchy hashbrowns
[Laughter]
you're holding it like a fish
i had an olympic phase watching porn
i did i did like it wait what well yeah
what do they do with the lymph nodes i
specifically look for
lipstick what do they do i specifically
look
for like uh search bar you typed [ __ ]
to flaccid penis
wow that was relatable to you face
flaccid or what happens
generally but i was always i was always
fascinated because i'm like man
like i don't know why i like that or
whatever but
in my head it was just like damn that's
so different
so wait the chick sucks the dick and
then it's length it's dangling
it's like pop pop wait does it start
hard and then
no it's just flaccid oh the whole time
it's flashing yeah so is there
the money shot it looks like an elephant
oh yeah you look for flaccid penis huh
well that's look at her face she doesn't
like it this is we're straight into that
yeah
oh i know why bother you guys
oh wow i mean it looks like she's
sucking on a pinky
that's not the kind i like it looks like
a like it's like
joe does that approve what's the kind
you look like it's kind of like that
that's a
that because they're all like you got
the ugliest girl though
oh yeah okay so porn star super hot
huge natural tits let's see there we go
hold on big naturals big fat now we're
just watching watching
she's pretty hot yeah that's a flaccid
penis
that is plus it just stays flat on the
whole oh oh oh i know why i know why
okay so my fat one
you guys done watching porn can you be
professional for a minute come on joe
we're just trying to watch the spots of
[ __ ] stuff
your buzz kill you know what i should
create some type of
law here because in any other business
this would be not
okay we're drunk we're watching porn i
let you guys drink alcohol
why can't we do drugs man let's do this
is [ __ ]
i'm just a guest um there's no
sexual harassment law in here says the
guy who's shirtless
you're the porn king dude how are you
offended no
i'm just saying that this is a
respectable place and i cannot condone
these things because what if someone
gets
hurt in the process it was because you
were like that's not the right one it's
because she wasn't hot enough
and that's all you're pissed about
curious about what your taste was
no okay so now that i have your
attention
and before you judge me because i don't
like to be judge-like we're not gonna
yuck your yum i
i think that the reason why i like uh
limp dick blow jobs is because one of my
dreams
is to get a blow jog while it's limp and
it gets hard
because i'm already hard
by the time my pants come off so i don't
know what that is like so i want i
am fantasizing about that that means
she's gotta start while you're sleeping
yeah true but he can't see it and enjoy
it but what if i wake up with a boner
she's gotta catch you off guard i want
to yeah i want to know what it's like
to yeah to rise to the occasion
instead of like being too turned on and
then it's like
man we have a couple what is the thing
that will like immediately
is a boner killer i just gotta go like
this you can't be too hot
no like that's your boner killer think
of something what is the thing that you
think of that is like immediately
no hard dick it's impossible kids wow
okay
good um okay okay yeah that's that would
make sense why
see that one like you could you could
tap into whatever it is that you need to
tackle
no bad answer no
so think of kids first is what tiff's
saying no because if i think of kids
i'm not going to want to do anything
after that
well then you have a limp dick what
about thinking about just your penis
getting cut off
immediately by like a chainsaw yeah how
about that see that's less that's less
totally just about you doesn't involve
evil for anybody else you're just you
drastically losing your people i'll try
it it might be hard but i'll try
you should look up that because there's
people that actually [ __ ] they do
that
it's called olympics i forgot like like
they cut their dick
they have a woman step on it with a high
heel shoe like they're literally like
tying up their dick and like the
watermelon challenge
and then they chop it off what the [ __ ]
do they not realize the permanent
situation that they're getting into
because uh it's extremely traumatizing
don't
pick it up have you seen why and julia
close your mouth
[Laughter]
no and then that same day i saw two
girls one cup and i was like this that's
enough for
the whole century yeah that's a
traumatic day on the internet wow why
would you watch two girls one cup
because i had never seen it during that
time this was like 2010-ish
everyone was talking about that no but
by the time i could smell [ __ ] now
old like everyone had already seen it
i'm like you're late to the game i'm so
missing out like i i need to understand
take us back to the black dick and then
cut it off scene oh
it's called something olympics i always
forget [ __ ] olympics
no something else choking olympics i
don't remember the rain above it
olympics
remember when people did the uh rick
rolling with
uh two girls one cup we were watching a
video about like an ostrich that's
falling over and then all of a sudden it
turns into two girls one cup out of
nowhere
yeah and that music and then people were
filming reactions without seeing the
computer screen and then people were
like
oh my god people were just like going
like this because it's like a fun
animal video and it's like oh [ __ ]
really fast yeah that shit's
traumatizing
there was a lift dick that got sucked
and we watched it together
we did
[Music]
you